une journée d'échange et de partage
autour de la lecture samedi 1er avril
avait lieu la remise du prix du livre de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines Daniel Picouly
président du jury nous explique
l'intérêt autour de ce salon c'est
surtout aussi les auteurs qui étaient là
les prix qui sont remis l'implication
j'aime beaucoup l'idée d'une implication
des médiathèques de d'un vote par
internet et tout ça c'est ça qui est
important ça veut dire que toute la
ville est un peu parti prenante de ces
prix dans la catégorie les visionnaires
évoquant des questions du monde de
demain c'est le dernier des sien de
Sybille Grimbert sur l'extinction des
espèces qui a été récompensée par les
lecteurs je rêvassais comme ça un jour
autour du dodo et je me disais c'est
dingue d'avoir été le dernier dodo
d'avoir commencé avec des semblables et
avoir terminé tout seul comme tout le
monde je crois que comme la sixième
extinction est un bruit de fond dans
lequel on est qu'on entend tout le temps
enfin c'est normal et c'est très bien
j'étais pas insensible à ce sujet les
élèves de 5e de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ont
sélectionné l'auteur du prix lire et
choisir dans cette catégorie Julia
billet l'emporte avec l'ouvrage la
guerre de Catherine c'est une jeune une
jeune adolescente qui est juive qui qui
est à la maison des enfants qui a un
lieu qui accueille des enfants en début
de la guerre et en 42 quand la rage du
Vél' d'Hiv est annoncé la directrice de
l'école décide de faire partir tous les
enfants juifs ça va être le récit de son
de son grand voyage de son périple au
travers de la guerre l'événement était
organisé par le réseau de médiathèques
de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines en
partenariat avec la radio marmite FM et
les librairies du pavé du canal et du
pavé dans la mare une cinquantaine de
petits et grands lecteurs étaient réunis
pour cette deuxième édition qui ne
devrait pas être la dernière